and I told the team uh these uh values
would be on the walls but more
importantly they would operate in the
Halls his CEO who goes by the name of
Cynthia not goes by the name her name is
Cynthia Marshall I suppose uh she is big
on Dei and here is a video of her
explaining why uh and how she believes
in Dei and what they should do about
people who do not believe in diversity
equity and inclusion we wanted to also
focus on emotional safety and I told the
team uh these uh values would be on the
walls but more importantly they would
operate in the halls and so then we went
through a series of uh sessions to
really dig into those values and what it
meant to have values-based employment at
the Dallas Mavericks and then the 100
day plan was in four parts and it was to
model zero tolerance so set up a hotline
complaint process Etc do an
investigation Purge what we needed to
purge uh a Mavs women's agenda so a very
uh descriptive agenda around elevating
empowering and just educating women uh
cultural transformation which is all the
things around diversity and inclusion
Employee Engagement our employee
resource groups just the things we
needed to do uh to institutionalize an
inclusive culture um and then
operational effectiveness basic things
like market-based compensation
performance reviews gender pay Equity
analysis all that so it was about 200
initiatives wo lady there is a lot there
now remember this is the CEO of the
Dallas Mavericks her job is to make the
Dallas Mavericks basketball team as
functional as possible Right to win as
much as possible to make as much money
as possible to bring in the proper coach
proper GM have the entire structure
there so they have the best freaking
basketball team so they sell out every
game so they have everyone watching
bring on the best players selling
jerseys etc etc everything she talked
about there had nothing to do with that
my friend Pete bagian who obviously has
been on the show many times he often
talks about this that once you allow
diversity equity and inclusion into any
company your eye is off the ball if your
job is to sell widgets and suddenly
you're deciding how many black
salespeople you have and how many white
janitors you have you're not going to
sell as many widgets well now you see
that a as a institutionalized piece of
what's going on uh with the Dallas
Mavericks a couple things she talked
about there they're going to have a
series of sessions based on values based
employment so it has less to do with I
don't know the work that you do the
value that you create it's going to be
about their values which of course have
something to do with race and racism
they're going to have zero tolerance I
guess that means if someone accidentally
misgenders somebody zero tolerance and a
hotline they also have a hotline that
you can call to basically rat out your
co-workers do we have a hotline like
that here there is a hotline I've been
uninformed about that
hotline